would you ever online date obviously
you're not your nose right now but no I
could never online day it's just so I
don't know sarah hyland doesn't need the
internet to find love stranger dangers
are online I'm not just in process you
just don't know I mean like 25 year olds
boyfriend is her former Vampire Academy
co-star Dominic Sherwood I think
communication is really beautiful and
that's the key to any relationship but
in her new film XOXO sarah's character
is siegel and it was like he knew would
be the perfect song to send to me now in
terms of your characters storyline it
really delves into some difficult but i
think necessary conversations yeah what
did you learn through that experience of
filming that my character crystal goes
through a lot in this she starts off
she's very naive and young and believes
in true love and so she meets a guy
online and they have plans to meet up at
this music festival called XOXO and
things don't go as planned for her and
there's some touchy subjects but it
doesn't get too much it's uncomfortable
but it's not the most uncomfortable the
Netflix movie begins streaming on August
26 that's cool that you like candy but I
want chocolate the kind you save for a
special occasion and eat slowly